so not to be left out of the release
game uh AMD dropped the RX 7600 today
their new
270 dollar Contender yep they dropped
the price 30 bucks since the
announcement so let's find out how this
Stacks up against the outgoing 6600 XT
right there and nvidia's offerings in
the same price point
[Music]
the montec Titan gold ATX 3.0 power
supplies feature a Gen 5 pcie power
connector for adapter free 40 series GPU
installation and is available in 750 850
1000 and 1200 watt versions giving you
the power needed to power today's
demanding PC components 100 Japanese
105c capacitors provide improved
performance while the 135 millimeter
fluid Dynamic bearing fan with zero RPM
mode keep all components cool even
during the most demanding workloads all
while the 80 plus gold rating and
10-year warranty provide end user Peace
of Mind check out the Titan gold lineup
of montec power supplies by clicking on
the sponsored Link in the description
below
all right so let's talk about the cards
that we chose for today's benchmarks and
where the 7600 fits into the current
landscape of pricing we went ahead and
tested it against the RX 6600 XT right
there which is its outgoing uh older
sibling however the 6650 XT is the
current offering right now uh we didn't
have one on hand but the pricing for the
6650 XC right now is right at 270 bucks
which is exactly where the 7600 is so
that's going to be an interesting
comparison we went ahead and threw in
the 6750 XC as well just to see what a
higher end offering
um for the next performance tier up from
AMD would look like we threw in the
Intel Arc a750 limited as well which is
an 8 gig card Intel's been improving the
driver uh pretty significantly recently
so we went ahead and retested the a750
limited to throw in those numbers and
see where it Compares right now now the
a750 is interesting because you can pick
it up for 250 bucks all the way up to
about 290 bucks for a slightly
overclocked custom card as far as the
Nvidia side of the comparison and we
went ahead and used the RTX 3060 Tough
by Asus and the RTX 3050 as well 3060
tough is going to be interesting to take
a look at because the cheapest 3060 I
could find on Amazon today was 315 and
that tough that specific tough model is
380 the tough does have a vram advantage
over the 7600 because it has 12 gigs of
vram versus the 7600s 8 as well as a
192-bit bus versus the 7600s 128-bit bus
however as you're going to see in these
slides
that's not really matter that much for
NVIDIA so without spoiling anything else
uh let's just jump right in on the
numbers
first off is Times by extreme 7600 did a
great showing here handily beating the
6600 XT Merc and the Nvidia cards are
just left in the dust down below the
a750 I think really likes the 3D Mark
Times by engine for some reason it is
scoring really high and even higher now
with the uh the new driver and the 6750
xde you're rounding up the top the other
synthetic test that we run is 3D Mark
Port Royal just to test how Ray tracing
performs again we see the 7600 solidly
beating 6600 XT
um no surprise there it should it's the
outgoing hard the 3060 tough puts up a
good fight against the 7600 in this test
however it still comes up short 3050 is
just it's it's just not anything right
home about here a750 again with its
newer RT cores which I Gotta Give it to
Intel
um for their first generation of Ray
tracing stuff
the arc series is punching way above its
way moving on to real world testing
we're going to start with Borderlands
three again no surprise the RX 6750 XT
is taking the top spot in this test that
being said Borderlands is again a very
AMD favoring title and so it's no
surprise to see the 3060 and the 3050
down at the bottom but the a750 still
doing a decent showing here in 1440p
it's right behind the 6600 XT it loses
over 10 frames in 1080P but hey the a750
is not doing that bad moving a lot of
cyberpunk no Ray tracing the 7600 scored
a good 10 FPS gain in 1080P over the
6600 XT Merc about the same FPS and 1440
as well the a750 climbs ahead of the
6600 XT in cyberpunk non-ray tracing
which is pretty interesting again like
I've said before Intel's driver team is
making huge strides in improving their
performance and it's been really
interesting to see the difference in
these uh these scores and no surprise as
usual the RTX 3060 and the 3050 rounding
up the bottom of the chart next up is
Forza Horizon 5 which is another
slightly AMD favoring title the 7600
pulls 92 FPS in 1080P just one FPS above
the 6600 XT so we didn't really see that
much of a generational Improvement in
this title
um two more FPS in 1440p again the 3060
tough is well below the 7600 about 20
FPS Below in Forza Horizon 5 at 1080p
it's not looking good for the Nvidia
cards in this comparison in Gears of War
5 we finally saw the 360 tough takea
technically a victory in 1440p got four
more FPS than the 7600 however it tied
at 1080p at 108 FPS exactly the 6600 XC
is a little bit behind the 7600 as well
and a750 down at the bottom Gears of War
really likes the 3060. it might have to
do with the extra vram that the 3060 has
the 7600 unfortunately takes another
loss in Guardians of the Galaxy non-ray
tracing to the 3060 tough however again
the 3060 at the cheapest is 315 dollars
which makes it 45 more dollars than the
7600 the 6600 XT is right behind the
7600 as usual only a few frames below
and the last traditional rasterization
test that we did which is shadow of the
Tomb Raider non-ray traced again pretty
much the same order 7600 at 141 FPS 6600
below that by a decent amount actually
10 FPS or 9fps less below the 6600 again
is the 3060 and the a750 and then the
3050 of course rounding up the bottom of
the chart so it's interesting that the
36C seems to trade blows with the a750
more so than competing with the 7600. in
almost all the cases the 7600 is
significantly above the 3060 tough and
that's the tough with the 12 gigs
instead of the 8 gig which it launched
with et cetera et cetera again that
tough that is in this chart is almost
actually it's more than a hundred
dollars more than the 7600 so this is
what looking better and better with each
chart okay so now we're going to move on
to Ray tracing tests now AMD is
traditionally been
lagging behind in its Ray tracing
technology so uh it's gonna be
interesting to see what the 7600 does
however all of these cards are low end
cards and so Ray tracing is almost like
oh cool it can do it versus something
that you're probably going to want to be
playing with um enabled the whole time
that being said let's go ahead and just
start with shadow of the Tomb Raider
with raytries and shadows enabled now
here you see nvidia's second gen RT
cores with the 3060 tough putting up a
much better fight against the 7600 ties
it in 1080 it actually essentially ties
it in both 1080 and 1440. there's one
FPS less for the 7600 to 4040p which is
within margin of error the 6600 has a
decent Gap below that owing to its
slower RT cores as well and a750 as much
as it tried it did only muster up about
76 FPS moving on to Metro Exodus is Ray
Trace mode Metro Exodus is an
interesting engine I think it very much
prefers the Intel Art card as the a750
is smack dab on top of this chart even
beating up the RX 6750xt from AMD which
was surprising and the only title that
it did this on 7600 has a decent lead
over the 3060 in Metro Exodus as well at
1080p as far as Guardians of the Galaxy
with Ray tracing enabled uh seems to
favor the Nvidia cards of course uh the
RTX 3060 tough is the one that's on top
of this chart with the 6750 not that far
behind and tying it in 1440p
the a750 then follows which is
interesting it's actually beating the
7600 by significant amount especially in
1440p the 7600 and the 6600 are pretty
much right behind each other and the
3050 rounding up the bottom of the chart
and last but not least the good old
cyberpunk 2077 Ray tracing Ultra preset
3060 tough taking the top score and this
one with 29 FPS at 1080p again as usual
these numbers are with no scalar Tech
enabled so no xcss no dlss no FSR for
all these cars just raw render me all
the pixels and then we'll worry about
the performance later on the thing to
note with our benchmarks is we always
test the hardest case like the worst
case scenario for each card so that way
you know that if these numbers aren't up
to what you want out of the card you can
always lower your graphic settings in
the game to get more performance out of
it a750 surprise us by only being one
FPS below the 3060 tough in Ray tracing
cyberpunk which is obviously a very
heavy test to run as far as RT goes
again Intel's RT cores even though their
first generation pretty much came out of
the gate swinging and it shows here the
7600 is actually below the 3050 in this
Ray tracing test with 16 FPS it didn't
do that much better than the 6600 as
well that's an interesting story as far
as really heavy Ray tracing
um with the 7600 so basically don't do
it don't run some super crazy RT on this
card unless you're expecting to have to
be using FSR at probably balanced or
performance or even Ultra performance
depending on the game
um you're gonna need to use FSR for
appreciable frame rates if you're going
to be hitting this tiny little thing
with a crap ton of rays for it to trace
all right so let's wrap things up with
the RX 7600 from AMD Jay and I went over
the charts and this thing has a lot
going for it alright so let's start with
the good it's outperforming the 6600 XT
at roughly the same price so
that's awesome because you don't have to
pay more money for more performance
you're paying the same money it's
solidly beating the 3060 and the 3050
the 3060 being significantly more
expensive and having more vram which is
really impressive for this lokai again
the 3060 was only really dominating in a
few tests
um
in the vast majority of the regular
tests um not including Ray tracing the
7600 was the card to beat now we had an
interesting showing from the Intel Arc
a750 with uh whatever the latest driver
is as far as May 2023 is concerned
however
it's still kind of
too inconsistent for me to recommend the
a750 especially because the a750 is only
coming out on top of the 7600 in Ray
tracing tests it almost seems like the
only time the other cards can really get
on top of the 7600 is when you throw
something that the 7600 is not very good
at which is very heavy Ray tracing
um as far as just rasterization
performance you guys saw the charts the
7600 is holding its own for sure the
only cons that I could really think of
was the fact that it was losing out in
Ray tracing performance to the 3060
however
the 3060 being 315 dollars at its
cheapest that I could find today again
May 2023. it's tough to recommend the
3060 over the 7600 when
it's only beating the 7600 and again
just like the a750 specific cases and
it's more pricey at the least if not
you're probably gonna be paying at least
350 to 380 for a 30 60. 315 one's
probably going to be gone soon so yeah
the RX 7600 is a solid Contender for
1080p gaming it's cheaper than 300 bucks
270 again as they after they lowered the
price and it's beating the Nvidia cards
that are significantly more expensive
and also have four more gigabytes of
vram and a larger bus this thing has
eight gigabytes of gddr6 with a 128-bit
bus whereas the 3060 tough has 12
gigabytes with a 192-bit bus so for the
3060s you'll still be losing to the RX
7600 even though this thing only has
only eight gigs of vram it's pretty
impressive for this thing it's not
really that good at Ray tracing
performance but I mean no surprise there
pretty much all these cards in this
price point are
in a bracket where I would consider RT
as a novelty as as opposed to something
that you would probably be gaming on
enabled 24 7 with your normal uh single
player titles and that sort of stuff
again it's going to be a great option
for 1080p at Max settings and like I
said earlier our benchmarks are always
at the highest presets so you you can
get more FPS if you just if you lower
your settings a little bit Jay thinks
that it's going to be a decent car to
1440p as well however you're probably
going to have to drop some settings and
you might be running into a little bit
of ram vram constraints without eight
gigabytes but 1440p is not that much
harder to run so yeah that's the AMD RX
7600 punching above its weight for 270
dollars especially when it comes to
competing against Nvidia the 3060 even
if you lower the price to match the 7600
it still doesn't win in enough charts
in fact it loses pretty significantly in
most charts and only takes wins in our
teeth and so it's very difficult to
recommend the 3060 in comparison to this
card the 7600 again I keep saying 270
bucks because that's just blowing my
mind that you know finally we're getting
dope performance in this price bracket
so yeah it's interesting to see how
amd's filling out this rdna3 uh product
stack it was interesting to drop this
super high-end cards and then go all the
way down to a 600 tier without an XT for
this card but looking around at its
competitors in the same price bracket
it's hard to not recommend anything but
the 7600 so what do you guys think of
these new cards coming out recently are
they finally starting to get into your
uh price range or are you still waiting
to see what the future of competition
shapes up to be sound off in the
comments below and as always we'll see
you guys in the next one